volunteers racing Against Time as deadly
fires rage out of control in Bolivia's
Amazon
region the fire has been Relentless
there have been lots of losses many
houses pastures and crops have been
damaged there's been almost 130 fire
outbreaks this month many of them caused
by Farmers clearing the land but with
the climate phenomenon in Nino hitting
South America this year temperatures are
higher and droughts more severe unable
to control the Flames Bolivia has
appealed for International
Help we've already made contact with
Nations such as France Chile Venezuela
and
Brazil Brazil is facing its own disaster
with fires destroying the panao the
world's largest tropical
Wetland we expect the effects of El Nino
to reach their peak in December and
we'll probably suffer the consequences
until next April with climate change
making things worse scientists say that
Eno and climate change have not only
caused drought in the Amazon they're
also responsible for unusually heavy
rainstorms in the south of Brazil
government officials say that this year
almost 6 million Brazilians have been
affected by extreme high temperatures
and
floods in the states of Hil Gru and
Santa Katarina more than 25,000 people
have been forced from their homes flood
hit the same region in southern Brazil
just two months ago killing almost 50
people Monica yanak Al jazer Rio de
Janeiro make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer